on the anniversary of Kobe Bryan's 81 18
years ago the inspiration has been going
around on the NBA we've had some special
performances tonight and we must start
with Joel embiid against the Spurs it
was all about Joel against wemi on this
night coming into the game but then it
all became about Joel because he went
for a franchise record in career high 70
points along with 18 rebounds and five
assists just incredible stuff from Joel
embiid
as he continued to dominate and when you
get your name in the record books
passing Will Chamberlain that's a pretty
special thing yeah you see wi wi wi wi
Alan Iverson um anytime you are on the
same list as Will Chamberlain I mean 70
tonight and the way that he did it was
just pure dominance sometimes you got to
show the new school that the old school
isn't broken and we're still here and
that's what Joel and andb did today
against wimy and he did in such a
fashion like he can do the thing that
was the scariest part for me if I'm an
opponent watching him beat was that he
can do it every single night it wasn't
anything he wasn't hot hidden shots from
half court he wasn't hidden threes he
only made one of them it was just the
fact that his dominance his mentality to
still Dominate and keep others involved
made his job so much easier it was a
historic night for him yeah and then
Carl Anthony towns goes for 62 points
breaking his own franchise record and
career high hit 10 threes in the process
but did miss the game winner with 1.7
seconds to go giving the Hornets the win
tough for towns but again what an
incredible night for him so you got two
players getting 60 plus in a single
night pretty rare when you consider the
last time that happened was
1978 yeah and you think cat had 58 after
three quarters he only scored Four
Points in the fourth quarter so he was
capable of getting 70 um I mean this
just speaks to the talent level in the
NBA right now it speaks to the video
game numbers that these guys are putting
in and and it speaks to the efficiency I
mean and it also speaks that The Bigs
are back I mean I understand this is a
guards league and and everybody says
that it's position basketball but bigs
being able to have size get in the paint
also shoot the three I mean it's a
luxury it is a luxury it also speaks to
the freedom of movement as well uh that
everybody's getting a chance to put up
these numbers but it's fun to watch and
to canas Point these guys are so evolved
right you look at these these bigs and
they're just like big guards now like
she is and it's just it's amazing
because they can do this every single
night they can dominate games in ways we
haven't seen before it's crazy when you
go specifically to Joel embiid and what
he's doing in the amount of time he's on
the court yeah 37 minutes that that
that's like scary like you would think
okay the numbers he put up they must
have went to four overtimes and he had a
hot night but it was like 37 minutes he
didn't force anything uh and he took the
this match up personal and that's what
makes great players great because
they're always looking for something he
knew Wy was coming to his house he
wanted to send a message that hang driil
left pullup that we saw tmac do and
Kevin Durant and guys like that he's
kind of transformed that it's become an
Unstoppable move for him it was a steady
di of that steady died of dominating
inside he did it all night did he even
see wimy G on that play what he do he
didn't see nobody he didn't see
anybody the John Cena but for real like
68 points in the paint I'm sure majority
of that was embid and for a night that
Philly only shot five of 20 from Beyond
The Arc this is a team that I think that
they could make some huge noise
especially with the way embiid is
playing now and his sheer dominance it
can make some noise come postseason they
just have to figure out how to continue
to play off each other because when you
have a guy like that that can easy put
up 40 just by lacing up his sneakers um
you know this is a talent you don't want
to waste crazy you only hit one
three-pointer in the game there one 3
how many memes are right there in the
bill oh uh there's at least three or
four okay all right let making
sure all sorts of ways he deserved it
though you want to get a jacket away we
I see you 3 get out the
way